this is Ken carpenter speaking from a
special booth on the stage of the RKO
Pantages Theatre in Hollywood the house
itself is jam with 3000 people I'm
outside Hollywood Boulevard is swarming
with other thousands and small wonder
1950s most distinguished film
achievements are about to be honored by
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences this is Oscar night this is the
money run sitting on my left in the
booth is actor John London during the
course of tonight's show he will chime
in to describe the action and keep radio
listeners abreast of what's going on
here in the theater right now the
overture is about to begin the Academy
Awards orchestra Alfred Newman
conducting
it's my pleasure with him seated with me
here in our ABC radio booth while of
Hollywood's brightest young stars mr.
John lund thank you Ken please excuse
the coupie voice I sound like this ello
that'll meet Lord well outside the
Pantages Theatre tonight there's
pandemonium
the crowd is milling around with
theatres the searchlights are roving the
sky in fact the scene is exactly like
the Colliers magazine cover of last week
the case of nature imitating art inside
their stillness and expectancy as the
orchestra is lowered into the pit
and the curtain rises reveal the station
it's a beautiful set too
director of artists Mitch license
classic white columns against the kind
of a watermelon colored background blue
foundation and in stage Center a giant
golden Oscar
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences
mr. Charles Brackett
fellow members of the Academy honored
guests ladies and gentlemen 20 served
presentation ceremony of this
organization honors the film
achievements of the year 1950 1950 do
you remember last December 31st did
Americans ever watch the passing of a
year with such a sense of relief the
year of Korea the year of malok the year
when the Russian land grab became a fact
the most obtuse could not ignore the
year when young American blood had been
spilled out terribly in what seemed like
defeat the year when household bomb
shelters became an item advertised in
local newspapers already the value and
importance of that year has become
obvious biologists shock treatment it
performed the same function of
clarification the pattern of our
American proposition emerged clear from
the farce of abuse and mistrust because
it was being maligned as an aggressor
and an imperialist the American man in
the street examined the social theory
which is his birthright with keener eyes
he found it valid and generous and
inescapable if the spirit of man is to
survive so much for the year in general
not about us in the industry during this
momentous stretch of time like the rest
of the country we stuck to our own job
that meant turning our pictures the big
divergent bunch of them pictures about
people with individual problems big ones
small ones people with widely different
ways of looking at things and laughing
at things the kind of people will used
to does that seem a paltry way to face a
time of crisis a frivolous use of days
whose dongs were sometimes frightened by
the glow of atomic doings in a nearby
state I don't think so I believe we were
affirming our faith in the importance of
individual man
and his god-given rights that we were
exalting his strange talents for Pride
and Kitty and laughter I believe we were
stating a new his wonder at Earth's
beauty and his mystification and grief
that his own folly surely these are
matters of high concern in a world and
at a time which has seen whole nations
of individual men obliterated by a
faceless wave I hope we'll be making
such diverse many-sided pictures for a
very long time and now ladies and
gentlemen our master of ceremonies last
year at this time the Board of Governors
of the Academy voted a special award
which met with wild enthusiasm from our
members it went to a great harvest who
raised the whole level of musical
pictures by his own bootstraps who could
more artfully take over this stage
tonight the mr. Fred Astaire
ladies and gentlemen I am grateful to
mr. Brackett for his splendid summary
and for suggesting how right I am for
this job however we must remember mr.
Brackett as a writer what he really
means is that I'm a hooker with a spare
set of tails if it's any comfort there
is a reason for my being here last year
for MC they chose mr. Paul Douglas one
of the new faces in films this year they
made a neat balance they've chosen one
of the oldest it was it was quite a
while ago when I first got out here I
guess the Academy Board thought that was
as good a reason as any to choose an MC
anyway
I'm most grateful for the honor and I'll
try I'll try my best mr. Brackett that
has covered the important aspects of
filmmaking for 1950
however he has not touched on some of
the divine flippin C's during the year
newspapers carried stories on a number
of weird and outlandish happenings
inspired by the making of motion
pictures
for instance in January a woman near
Lakeland Florida told her husband she
was going to the movies she came out of
the show beat up a cop and shot a
drugstore clerk in jail she explained
the whole incident by saying I always
get a big kick out of more than a pigeon
yeah
Neera
here in Hollywood there were a few like
trends movies began to feature talking
animals it got so bad that one Boston
Bank is said to have withdrawn its
backing on a picture when they caught
the producer trying to use a human being
1950 was also the year of the small dark
cloud a new medium of entertainment
began to grow and experts said it was
keeping more and more people at home I
refer of course to camasta tonight is
Oscar night the prizes are being given
for 1950s most distinguished film
achievements the prize itself is a 10
inch statue with 41 dollars but it is
fought for trade for wept over believes
me Caesar's legions did not fight harder
for the jewel of Gaul these these awards
are arrived at by a carefully guarded
system of balloting 12,000 people took
part in the voting this year the
nominations were made by the members of
the Academy branches assisted by the
Hollywood guild the final selections
were voted by the nearly 2,000 members
of the Academy all ballots were mailed
to the accounting firm of Price
Waterhouse where they've been properly
accounted and certified the results were
placed in sealed envelopes and brought
to this stage opening those envelopes is
the business at hand but before we hit
the glory trail I have a note here on
the margin well it again has to do with
thank-you speeches from the winners if
you will allow me I must convey a
request from the board asking that you
make them as short as possible as you
know in the past we've had little
trouble with people who have come up on
the stage with a long list of people to
thank that was then there was one year
at Grauman's a girl took a Beverly Hills
phonebook up with her
another time another time down at the
Shrine Auditorium an actor started in we
never did get him back this this is not
a gag rule feel free to speak your piece
but please just try to remember on a
radio network it's always later than you
think